on passe à un autre sujet celui des
accompagnantes des sorties scolaires qui
sont souvent des mères de famille qui
sont mises à contribution
vous savez qu'à l'école on ne doit pas
avoir de signe distinctif en tout cas
religieux pour les professeurs comme
pour les élèves et les maires sont elles
concernées par ce sujet c'est l'avis de
parlementaires qui avaient qui voulait
faire passer un article en ce sens dans
une loi qui est en train d'être votée
sur l'éducation nationale mais jean
michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation a décidé
c'est niet
je pense que c'est un sujet qui ont été
finalement ne relève pas de la loi en
revanche la promotion de la laïcité au
quotidien ça oui vous savez très bien je
suis très mobilisé sur le sujet de la
laïcité nous devons être très attentifs
à cette question nous avons pris toute
une série de mesures en la matière pour
la faire respecter nous avons demandé
des équipes qui viennent dans les
établissements lorsque des problèmes se
posent
et donc nous sommes vraiment à
l'offensive sur ce sujet voilà et cette
décision du gouvernement
donc ce refus de d'interdire le voile
pour les mères accompagnatrices n'est
pas complètement nouveau
dès le mois dernier gabriel attal qui
est secrétaire d'état qui seconde
jean michel blanquer re l'avait déjà
laissé entendre en utilisant le mot qui
fâche il ne faut pas stigmatiser terrain
débat un serpent de mer qui revient
depuis des années
quand on n'est pas dans l'école on n'est
pas dans l'école et ça sert à rien
d'essayer de faire de la politique de la
stigmatisation symbolique à travers cet
amendement l'a dit les skis c'est une
surprise cette décision du gouvernement
où on pouvait s'y attendre après ce
genre de déclarations écoutez j'avais
écrit justement avec régis debray un
guide pratique de la laïcité ou en
revenait sur cette question je crois
qu'il faut faire une différence entre ce
qu'est le temps scolaire et ce qui n'est
pas du temps scolaire en rappelant quand
même qu'en france ce qui est obligatoire
c'est l'instruction publique et qu'elle
se fait soit à domicile soit dans un
établissement à caractère propre soit
dans l'école publique
le compromis qui a été long à trouver
sur ce sujet fait que les parents
républicains sont en droit de considérer
qu'il ne doit pas y avoir d'influencé
pendant le temps scolaire religieuse sur
leurs enfants
moi je pense
que le temps d'accompagnement pendant
une sortie qui est organisé par un
enseignant est un temps scolaire et qu'à
partir de là il vaudrait mieux ne pas
avoir le sentiment d'une pression
religieuse
l'idée du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui est de dire il faut régler
au cas par cas
c'est quelque chose qui est en réalité
un praticable puisque c'est d'une
certaine manière par la négative la gnrh
prudence lionel jospin après laffaire de
creil on avait dit qu'on régler au cas
par cas
or on ne peut pas régler au cas par cas
dans le cadre d'une communauté
enseignante qui est profondément divisée
sur ce sujet est donc le seul qui a
while harper aussi parce qu'il ya une
pression des parents dans certaines
écoles de banlieue où il ya une majorité
de maires qui sont où aller et qui
j'imagine d'un va leur mot à dire
le plan moiry à dire sur quoi bein sûr
le fait de deux sur le temps scolaire
alors marsaoui sur la tension et le
temps scolaire
moi je ne crois pas je ne crois pas
qu'elles sont leurs mots à dire sur le
temps scolaire parce que elles peuvent
la voir sur ça mais à ce moment là si on
dit qu'elles ont quelque chose à dire
sur le temps scolaire
j'étais en fonction seine-saint-denis
pendant trois ans j'ai été dans le rhône
vous pouvez avoir des demandes à partir
de convictions religieuses qui peuvent
devenir très très particulier la
séparation entre garçons et filles dans
la classe vous pouvez avoir ça mais je
crois que la distinction c'était temps
scolaire temps périscolaire dans le
temps périscolaire il peut y avoir des
sorties on peut demander le mercredi
après midi 1 des mers d'accompagner ou à
des pères dur est d'accompagner s'ils le
souhaitent les enfants pendant le temps
scolaire
je pense que vous pourriez avoir une
réaction de parents républicain qui vous
diraient mes - je trouve pas acceptable
que ce soit accompagnée par des mères
qui ostensiblement manifeste lors leurs
convictions religieuses
je ne peux pas moi accompagner parce que
par ailleurs j'ai d'autres obligations
je travaille où j'ai un autre enfant que
je dois garder et donc je ne veux pas
mon enfant soit là dessus et je pense
que il ya là quelque chose qu'il faut
d'une certaine manière finir par régler
de manière claire parce que sinon on va
avoir de plus en plus de
deux sujets de ce type avait dans
l'enseignement secondaire et même
enseignement supérieur des jeunes femmes
qui ne comprennent pas la limite entre
ce qu'est la laïcité est ce qu elle
n'est pas en ciment là deux poids et
deux mesures
laurent papier ce que le libéral que
vous êtes sans doute considère que c'est
la liberté individuelle qui doit il doit
l'emporter sur ce genre d'allégations
dégâts dans un cas particulier dans la
mesure où on est dans une école après
j'ai toujours du mal avec le l'état qui
réglemente quel beau petit siona droit
de porter ou pas et est bien sûr ça une
charge symbolique et la question c'est
est-ce que c'est ostentatoire est ce que
ça porte préjudice aux enfants est ce
que c'est un les ratios sont à thouars
quand même place ce genre de voix je
pense que c'est là je vais je vais être
dans la réponse du cas par cas quand
même parce que ça peut ne gênait
personne ça peut ne pas gêner les
enfants et et ça peut ça peut être un
peu tolérants vis-à-vis de ça ça peut
aussi générer des conflits et dans ce
cas là je pense que c'est plutôt du rôle
du professeur des écoles ou de houe de
l'école de fixer un certain nombre de
règles en cas de conflit mais en faire
une affaire d'état en faire une loi
après ça la question du voile c'est
toute façon on revient à la question du
voile c'est un c est ce que c'est
important de quelque chose française à
maintenir jeu
tout ça est dans un contexte où pareille
par exemple on a des femmes iraniennes
qui essaye de se battre bien sûr le
droit de l'enlever et cette idée voilà
mais le voile est un est un symptôme de
la problématique de la liberté
individuelle
ouais supérieure à toute loi c'est ce
qui a été la pratique d'un certain
nombre de nos voisins qui aujourd'hui
l'un après l'autre revienne sur sa le
dernier c'est l'autriche mais
l'angleterre 1 est revenu sur ce type de
pratique parce que elles sont allés
beaucoup trop loin
les pays bas l'ont fait il ya déjà
quelques années et donc on sent bien que
en la matière je dirais que c'est la loi
qui libère un et pas la loi qui opprime
enfin si je t'amène est juste mais si je
peux apprendre là dessus je pense que ça
reste un symptôme et je pense pas que là
dessus
je fais souvent d'accord avec le le la
république en marche mais il ya quand
même je passe sur qu'on règle ce genre
de problème avec de la stigmatisation en
en faisant une affaire d'état avec une
joie c'est quand même d'estimer tease à
sion c'est quand même empêcher une
personne
après ça dépend si elle est dans une si
cette personne est dans une posture où
je le fais pour provoquer oui là ça peut
poser un souci ça gêne personne
il faut pas en faire une aire si je vous
donne le point de vue des internautes
avant de continuer le tour de table
selon vous par souci de la laïcité
fallait-il interdire le voile lors des
sorties scolaires
vous êtes 71% à répondre oui voici deux
points de vue qui sont opposés c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont intéressants celui
de laly qui nous dit la laïcité ça veut
dire que chacun a le droit de choisir sa
religion et d'exercer librement les
pratiques qui concerne cette religion
donc les musulmanes devraient être
libres devraient être par don libre de
mettre le voile quand elles le veulent
alors que nicole considèrent au
contraire qu'une sortie scolaire se fait
dans le cadre de l'école et qu'on doit
donc respecter la laïcité
même lors de ses sorties votre point de
vue judith waintraub considérer que le
voile c'est un bout de tissu s'est passé
complètement à côté d'eux c'est ce que
vous avez dire
les bas pour iweb enfin tous des voleurs
implantation à leur portée après que ce
budget supporter un symbole fort c'est
bien sûr je lui dis parce que quand vous
dites ça ça ça commence très mal
le voile est un symbole de quoi d'un
projet politique qui s'appelle l'islam
politique qui est un projet concurrent
du projet républicain
en fait alors non il suffit de lire ça
fait dix-sept répétez souvent les
musulmanes vous pouvez très bien dans
les justes mais il n'a pas dit sur
l'adjectif derrière le port du voile il
faut les croire
je me pense que si on est sérieux c'est
sa liberté de toutes leurs devants dès
le le le voile tels qu'ils les portent
est là et le signe d'adhésion un projet
politique quand je suppose et à partir
de pernicieux j'effectue mon nom je vous
perdez ce match tu es bon d'accord veut
pas très libère finalement beaucoup ça
qui verra les autoritaires je suis
libéral un public est libérale
autoritaire
donc c'était assez c'est un projet
politique qui conteste les principes
républicains parmi lesquels la laïcité
contrairement à ce que dit notre
internaute la laïcité c'est la
séparation des églises et de l'état et
le fait que l'état de subventionner ne
reconnaît aucun culte
c'est pas ce que dit l'internaute et
quand ils qui contestent aussi l'égalité
hommes femmes
vous dites tuto sur la pétition la
république en marche quelle position
quand emmanuel macron vous explique que
le voile ne correspond pas à notre
conception
des rapports entre les hommes et les
femmes sur d'accord sur la question de
la stigmatisation
maintenant je pense pas qu'on puisse
présupposés directement l'opinion
politique d'une musulmane qui porterait
un voile au fait même qu'elle porte un
voile il peut y avoir des cas radicaux
il peut y avoir mais ça peut être
qu'elles peuvent
il faut être un peu marxiste c'est à
dire qu'on peut être pris par une
idéologie dominante sans en avoir
conscience
c'est l'apport de 2 mars enfin je te
plaît un peu à gauche et pas libéré quoi
je vais pas dire que toutes les femmes
qui portent un voile est un projet
politique poudre d'imposer un islam nos
politiques la signification du donc il
faut pas alors c'est cavale dans le
doute il faut laisser faire ce qu'elles
veulent ou dans le doute il faut leur
demande et obtenir
je comprends pourquoi le gouvernement à
reculer parce que c'était un amendement
et ne maîtrisait pas la chronologie mais
je suis favorable à une loi qui
interdirait les freins qui imposerait la
neutralité pour les accompagnateurs
scolaire à une époque circulait alors
oui c'est très compliqué parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de jurisprudence différent de
dire tribunaux sur le sujet mais
justement ben moi je serais pour
clarifier avec une avec une loi à mon
avis il faut pas se focaliser
spécifiquement sur justement les femmes
voilées
il faut se dire est ce que vous seriez
content qu'un quimper par exemple se
rendent à la sûreté scolaire avec un tee
shirt de la manif pour tous ou alors un
t-shirt ni dieu ni maître
ça c'est un affichage de convictions
politiques qui seraient pas du tout
accepté et c'est un peu la même chose
pour les pour les signes religieux c'est
la neutralité en fait et en fait l'idée
c'est que la l'école publique française
c'est un sanctuaire qui protège les
enfants des pressions politiques
religieuses et qui fait d'eux des
citoyens éclairés c'est comme disait
jean zay un asile inviolable où les
querelles d'hommes n'entre pas donc
l'idée et on va vous me dire les sorties
scolaires c'est pas à l'école oui mais
c'est pas des balades c'est pas des
promenades les sorties scolaires
c'est l'école hors les murs donc il nous
sommes assez légitime d'exiger des
parents ils nous sommes que c'est pas
une exigence démesurée que le temps de
la sortie scolaire il ya une certaine
neutralité pour que y ait aucune
pression sur sur les élèves je suis
entièrement d'accord là dessus mais la
question c'est est-ce que le voile porté
un voile fait partie de la neutralité ou
pas et je pense pas qu'on puisse
considérer comme afficher de manière
provocante je pense pas qu'on puisse
considérer que
c'est quelque chose qui est fait est
fait pour faire renoncer partie de
l'argumentation que j'essaye d'avoir qui
est de dire qu' il peut y avoir des
parents républicain qui trouve sympa
normal qu'il y ait à côte à côté de
leurs enfants
quelque chose qui est une manifestation
religieuse dans un cadre juridique qui
est que ce n'est pas l'école publique
est obligatoire c'est de l'instruction
publique et qu'on peut avoir le choix
dans ce pays de faire une instruction
dans un lycée ou dans un établissement à
caractère propre comme il y en a et donc
il ya quelque chose quand même qui est
de dire mais attention on ne peut pas au
monde du droit d'une certaine minorité
brimer une autre qui a quand même mené
un combat historique et celui de la
firme question pour un parent d'élève
qui porterait une croix très discrète on
est justement cette question a déjà été
réglée puisque la loi de 2004 interdit
les signes ostentatoires donc une petite
croix discrète que personne ne voie sauf
à bien regarder ça ne pose pas problème
une immense croix ça pose problème ou
une kippa sa possession sur des signes
ostentatoires
pourquoi la loi a pris cette forme de là
parce que c'était impossible d'interdire
le voile mais notre discussion montre
bien que le voile pose évidemment un
problème spécifique et pourquoi en soit
c'est pourquoi dans certains sur le fait
toujours que c'est déjà la règle commune
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
quand on canton
on voit sur des sites pour acheter une
croix catholique par exemple vous n'avez
pas comme argument de vente ça vous
rendra pudique s'avoue dissimulera au
regard des hommes vous n'avez pas être
satellisés la bouffe et de la théologie
ces panneaux seront ou non c'est pas la
théologie commencent à jeter n'importe
quel site de vente de mode public
puisque on appelle ça la mode public
utilisent ces arguments jouent nos défis
devant trouver un qui n'utilisent pas
ces arguments qui vous le dis juste que
ça vous va bien au visage et que ça va
ça mais votre teint en valeur mais très
bien c'est systématiquement cet argument
ne s'est pas en débat sur le vol qu'on
est ici c'est un débat sur la neutralité
mais sur le oui mais c'est pas vraiment
le débat une science du voile c'est le
débat ces suidés de l'ostentation
religieuse lithiques un signe n'est pas
porteur d'une idéologie c'est quand même
un peu particulier moi je suis d'accord
avec vous mais c'est plus in dans ce cas
le mail à tous les six mois j'étais au
lycée pas très loin d'ici
1 la question pouvait se poser pour
d'autres confessions et elle ne se
posait pas parce que il y avait une
règle un kit et wick ont intégré qui
était qu on ne faisait pas voilà mais ça
c'était donc et donc le recul de ce on
ne le faisait pas pose un problème
général je dirais de paix civile
on peut pas le dire autrement puisque
déjà sur ce plateau on sent bien qu'il
ya un peu de tension
donc voilà il ya un passionnant voilà
est elle donc du coup je pense que pour
éviter un débordement
voilà il faut un moment donné une ride
et le problème c'est que l'absence de
lois mais pas les enseignants parce que
c'est aussi ça parce que rappelez vous
que la sphère de d'aubervilliers avec
les soeurs les deux soeurs qui avaient
décidé de porter un voile c'est parce
que la communauté enseignante s'est
déchiré que ça a débordé l'espace public
que des politiques sauront été obligé de
s'en saisir et on aura de nouveau des
choses comme ça et donc le seul moyen
d'éviter à chaque fois une tension aux
extrêmes sur cette question là c'est de
mettre une règle dont la position des
sénateurs d'ailleurs évoqué un visuel
et de ce point de vue là le libéralisme
d'être malade la loi à peu créé aussi un
problème là où il y en avait par la loi
que veut créer un problème aussi quand
il n'y en avait pas où tout se passait
très bien avec des accompagnatrices qui
qui portait un voile et et quand ça non
mais ça c'est ça peut exister ça peut
exister dans certaines écoles où il ya
aucun souci là je pense qu'il faut
laisser de ce que les tirs d'angleterre
pendant très longtemps laissé le soin de
décider au niveau des écoles à ce moment
là les choses qui donnent le droit aux
écoles de fixer ces règlements au cas
par cas quand il ya des conflits fin
c'est pas nécessaire d'en faire une
affaire d'état
ça s'est vraiment animée cadre
républicain où il ya la commune pour
tous même temps il ya plusieurs
conservatoires ce n'est pas forcément
inquiet qu'elle peut être du ressort du
règlement intérieur de 6,1 points de vue
majoritaire au consensus suffisant à
l'intérieur d'une école ou d'un lycée le
la sphère d'aubervilliers
c'est exactement les le cas inverse
c'est à dire vous avez des des
enseignants qui je dois dire était
quasiment tous à gauche en plus un et
qui se sont très largement empaillés
pour faire un débat public était repris
à l'époque non pas par la gauche que par
d'autres
ça a été à l'origine de cette loi de
2004 interdisant donc les cibles
attentatoires il ne faut pas stigmatiser
je rappelle que dans l'espace public en
général on peut porter son voile
on peut porter sa kippa on peut porter
sa grande croix ça ne pose pas de
problème mais l'école c'est quelque
chose est un sanctuaire qui est
historiquement construit de manière
particulière avec des compromis qu'il
est très difficile de remettre en cause
son refaire jouer la question scolaire
merci de cet échange de points de vue
passionnant on passe à un autre sujet si
vous le voulez bien le procès de
l'ancien maire de levallois patrick
balkany touche à sa fin il ya
réquisitoire sévère certains diraient
très